a hobby of making candles turns into big
business for a las vegas woman
so big in fact she's opened her own
store simply pleasing candle company is
located on the west side it's rainbow in
charleston
as victoria saha reports what is so
special about michaela shorts shop
is that's the first black owned candle
company in the valley
simply pleasing candle company is the
definition of how
shopping small can go a long way i
completely thought it would be like a
family type of thing
i didn't think the rest of the world
would accept it but
i'm very grateful that they did makayla
shorts has always
loved candles but the start to her
business came to her
in a dream back in september it was
actually like candles by michaela
and that was my dream and it was sitting
on someone's shelves and i didn't know
it would be my own
shorts says she started her online
business in november
but the number of orders quickly outgrew
her home which led her to open this shop
on south of rainbow boulevard
and she says she will continue to expand
master bedroom looked about just like
this just with
ikea shelves all over the room and just
this week she found out she was the
first
black-owned candle shop owner in las
vegas her advice to other entrepreneurs
i don't know anyone who's running a
business like personally where i can go
ask some questions
so i would say just do it you just you
just have to do it
short says the pandemic made her realize
how quickly a study income can be taken
away
and she was grateful to have her candle
business to support her family
victoria saha 8 news now
so for those of you who might be
interested in learning how to make your
own candle
shorts is going to be having a class in
july and we'll have information up on
our website at 8newsnow.com for that